Visiting Angkor in Cambodia is a must if you are into architecture,...
...because it is considered one of the Seven Wonders of the World.
The buildings are truly one of humanity's most astonishing achievements.
To give you a historic background,...
...Angkor was discovered hidden in the jungle only in the late 19th century.
Isn't it astonishing to imagine that it was an ancient city...
...that had a population of one million people in its heyday?
The temples were crafted by the Khmer civilization between 802 and 1220 A.D.
From here, the Khmer kings ruled over a land...
...that stretched from Vietnam to China and the Bay of Bengal.
When you visit Angkor, it is not possible to see everything on foot.
If you don't want to be too tired in this place, it is advisable to hire a local guide...
...who can explain the background and answer questions...
...while transporting you from sight to sight.